the problem with this book is that it
has busted open
that old and still raw wound
and at a time when it was just beginning
to heal
this is clearly a couple who feel quite
aggrieved
um by the fact that they've never been
able to answer their critics
they've never been able to address
incorrect
reporting and i think this book is being
used
to correct some of the myths that were
perpetuated through the tabloids
they feel megan particularly that she
has been muted
for most of her royal life as short as
it was the sussexes have denied that
they have spoken to
um either carolyn durant or omid scobee
this was an announcement that came out
of their official camp
just a day ahead of the serialization
omid scobee was also asked in an
interview with andrew billing from the
times whether he had spoken to meghan
and harry
either on or off the record and omid
said he hadn't spoken to the couple
nonetheless
there has been a lot of speculation that
the
the sussexes have actually been involved
with this book and i think
what's very clear is that they have
wanted to get
their side of the story across megan
certainly has felt frustrated
by being a royal that she wasn't able to
speak out
that she wasn't able to address her
critics and
clearly whether or not she has directly
spoken with one or both of the authors
she has certainly allowed confidence
close friends and sources to speak on
her behalf
and that is quite simply to get her side
of the story out there
i haven't read the book in full and no
one has in fact even oprah
wasn't able to get an advanced copy of
this book it has literally been kept
under lock and key by the times and the
sunday times having myself written
royal biographies um i think it's fair
to say this is no andrew morton's diana
however the level of detail in this book
is quite remarkable what the authors
have managed to do
is get a level of detail which is
unprecedented
it's very clear that they have had
access to
sources incredibly close to megan and
harry
not just over mix it but from the very
beginning of their love story
this book lifts the lid on when the
engagement
actually took place which was weeks
before it was made official
we get some really remarkable details
about those first dates this is not
necessarily
shocking new revelations i think the
story is familiar to all of us now but
this is the first time we are hearing it
really from harry and megan's
perspective this has made the book
compelling
and fascinating but for the royal family
yes this book has been damaging because
it has
opened up old wounds the very term mexic
very clearly put the blame as it were on
megan
you know this was megan's decision to
leave to lead the royal family to leave
britain
and she was taking harry with him there
were even rumors that she said to him
i'm going with or without you
um it's actually my understanding and
and
this is also explored in finding freedom
that it wasn't
just megan's decision you know i think
harry was very much a driving force
you know people don't perhaps give harry
enough credit harry is a pretty
opinionated in the strong-willed man
um and it was always my understanding
i've been told by
several very well-placed sources that it
wasn't just megan you know dragging
harry away
she was the catalyst for making it
happen she gave him a new confidence
but actually i think the truth is that
for a long while
prince harry has wanted out this was a
prince who'd spoken quite vocally
about um the restrictions of of being a
royal
the weight of burden a boy who said
he wished he hadn't at times been born a
prince
so i think that says a lot about prince
harry and i think megan really just
gave him that confidence that there was
another route to explore that they
didn't have to live this life
and i think the problem was that their
lives had become
so unhappy and so miserable that
actually that other route which harry
had always toyed with
suddenly became a real and attractive
possibility clearly the way the couple
handled their departure from the firm
caused a lot of damage and that is
something that finding freedom explores
and i don't think it was a secret
it was no secret that the queen the
senior members of the royal family
were were disappointed but deeply hurt
by how harry and megan chose to launch
their departure from the royal family
but i think the family had moved on from
that there was an acceptance that this
was what was going to happen
harry and megan were going to start
their new lives and i think
that they were on a path to moving on
the problem with this book is that it
has busted open
that old and still raw wound
and at a time when it was just beginning
to heal
you